en
direct ce soir puisque notre émission
est en direct chaque séance et notre
slogan et nous y tenons et puis et puis
il ya la chanson lumière pourquoi la
chanson lumière avec un nom comme le
mien c'est normal et bien la chanson
lumière tout simplement parce que chaque
semaine un nouveau succès un récent
succès et sa vedette et son interprète
seront associés à une ville de france
les téléspectateurs de cette ville
devront décerné une note de 0 à 100 à
cette chanson liminaire tout simplement
en allumant chez eux une ou plusieurs
langues c'est amusant du avec la lumière
seagate en arts visuels dans la maison
alors vous allumez d'élan uniquement des
lampes sinon vous feriez sauter le
dispatching edf et cette consommation de
lumière supplémentaire nous sera
indiquée par le centre génial pdf est
ici dans quelques instants nous aurons
exactement ce chiffre 1 la maison c'est
notre rêve alors la première ville qui
joue avec nous ce soir et c'est
important je tiens à le préciser parce
que toutes les sept semaines ne feront à
classement de ses supporters c'est très
à la mode les supporters en ce moment et
la ville gare était la meilleure
supporters de sa jeune vedette et de son
succès recevra après groupe renaissance
avant ce plan alors oui la première
ville est bien la première ville
désignée c'est une très grande ville
puisque c'est toulouse 1 c'est quand
même pas mal soyons francs et la vedette
qui lui est associé c'est une jeune
découverte 71 esther galil sa chanson le
jour se lève qui a d'ailleurs gagné la
rose d'or voilà à antibes je sais tout
qu'est-ce que je suis un téléspectateur
de toulouse à blanc alors de gérer pour
la note attribuée à esther galil qui de
toute façon à une note maximum dans
notre coeur pendant la diffusion et
l'interprétation de sa chanson après ce
sera trop tard voici esther galil la
chanson lumière le jour se lève
[Applaudissements]
l appareillage appel
sans prière de toulouse pour connaître
les résultats de notre chanson lumière à
l'eau toulouse wikileaks alors alors
qu'elle est ce résultat un chiffre est
en train de s'inscrire sur notre cadran
et c'est exact d'ailleurs je le vois
monte ça monte toujours avant tout un
sauna 60-70 se montre le la smac est
dépassée façon ça s'arrête top 89
combien 89 89 pas des toits c'est une
très belle note accordée par toulouse ça
du marché les petites lumières à
toulouse merci habite toulouse voilà eh
bien je croyais avoir été assez obscur
dans mes explications grâce à cette
chanson lumière j'ai été lumineux merci
[Musique]